[Music]
Pierre Conissa, hello, hello. We're
interviewing you today for a
YouTube channel called Serview. We've already had you on to discuss
counter-radicalization policies, and we spent
a little time talking about your
book, "Guide to Paradise: A
Comparative Guide to the Afterlife," which made us
laugh, taught us, and made us think. We
found it
so enjoyable that we finished it. We
could compare this
book—in our internet lingo—to a
Lonely Planet, a Trip
Advisor, or a Rough Guide to
Paradise, mixed with
George Carline's touch of humor and cynicism. And that's already quite something.
Pierre Conissa,
tell me a little about the genesis of this
book. This book is a few years old now,
and it stemmed from the observation
that it was related to my activities as a
strategist. Yeah, yeah, do you want me to
close it or not? No, just the collar...
Ah, okay, it's not Allezas, so... So,
I'll start again... So this...  The book is
already a few years old; it
stemmed from my observations from when
I was working on
strategic affairs. It was a
common-sense observation:
all major religions were
affected by forms of
radicalization, and generally, all these
radicalizations shared a
common promise: guaranteeing
access to paradise. Then came
the Iraq War, and during that
war, I asked myself a
question—a question of
common sense, really—since each side was
fighting in the name of God (
remember, George Bouche spoke of
a crusade), and the opposing side was essentially
mobilized around the anti-
crusade, that is,
jihad. I wondered,
ultimately, do the Americans killed by the
Iraqis go to the
Christian paradise or the Muslim hell,
and vice versa? It's a
legitimate question because you can't
start a war without having
answered it. So, I thought, since then...
While men are busy fighting
to explain
that they have one
merciful God, the only way to
reconcile all these theories is
to say that there are several
unique gods. And that is indeed the only
logical explanation for the
different descriptions of paradise in
different
religions. So I thought, if this is where
we're going to spend most of our
time—because it is, after all,
eternal life—it's better to
learn about the characteristics of
each paradise. Because if we
simply inherit our
parents' religion, we find ourselves steered towards it at the end
of our lives without having done, how should I say, a
market analysis. If
we consider that the only law
truly respected by all
religions is the law of the market, and that
Adam Smith's invisible hand is
probably the hand of God, I thought
the consumer needs to be
informed. So I tried to
describe this book, that is to say,
ultimately, what differentiates
all these paradises, and what is the best
way to access which one?  than that one,
and especially if you like,
it's an extremely interesting economic landscape
because there's a duopoly,
roughly speaking,
Christianity and Islam. There's a
very well-defined SME, the
Jewish community, which is practically sanctified and
therefore doesn't try to encroach on the
other two. And then there's a
fantastic startup market, that of
cults, which is constantly renewing itself
with new promises,
new explanations, and
new messiahs. So I thought, indeed, it's worth taking a look at the
market. You've looked a
little bit into the Church of Scientology?
Oh, well, of course, yes, of course, because
precisely, the market is renewed by
cults. That's what's
most dynamic today: sectarianism
affecting
Judaism, Islam, and
Christianity alike. The differences are simply that
in Christianity, in
Sunni Islam, and in
Shia Islam, there are...
religious hierarchies exist in some religions, while in
others they don't, so it's
always very difficult to classify them
as sects because, in fact, these religions,
Sunnism and Judaism, have
always been accustomed to people suddenly
announcing themselves as the
Messiah and developing
a new practice. But the fact remains that
when we use the sociology of
sects, we realize that
it is indeed a renewal
of the market through a
perpetually new promise, such as
the Church of Scientology, the Order of the
Solar Temple, Jim Jones, Syana,
and so on. So I thought, well,
my book is aimed at the
Western consumer, so to avoid disappointment
and, how should I say, getting lost in
sects like Buddhism or
Hinduism, which don't have
representative offices here, if we are disappointed by this
kind of approach, there's no
way to complain afterward. So I say let's stick
to the offering as it is
structured today, that is to say...  on
the major religions present in
France, including the
phenomenon of cults, so I
tried to do this like a
travel guide, that is to say, well, to
know the market, to know the
characteristics of each offer,
how to get there, how to earn
free miles, and so on, and you ask yourself 10
questions, then you
choose one, or any of them,
how to get there—
ah, that's a question of
location, geographically, because first
you have to make the
choice, obviously choose the
paradise that best suits your means
and tastes. Well, you see, for
example, in Buddhist Paradise,
theoretically the end of the process
becomes a kind of world where you no longer have
any desires. Well, if that's the paradise you're
waiting for, you'd better know,
so let's forget about that kind of
religion. On the other hand, there are religions
that have very, how to say,
very precisely defined offers, including in
particular the Muslim offer, and so I thought, once you've
chosen the
site, the next question comes, that is
to say...  Where to start from, because
obviously, as always, there are
always questions about the
appropriate departure point. So, the first point
I make is that you should
avoid peak departure times, meaning
weekend departures. Yes,
especially those involving massacres and
genocides, because there's a
risk of overcrowding. So it's
better to leave when you've chosen the right time.
Secondly, you have to choose the location. There's
a hub problem, which
is Jerusalem, meaning
everyone claims Jerusalem as the
perfect departure point to go directly
to
paradise. There are, however, some
secondary departure points because,
like all major airports such as
Dubai, Jerusalem is congested by the
number of people who come there to
die. Well, there are secondary departure points
depending on the nature of the
religion you choose. It might be the Muslim community, it might
be heavy traffic, it might be, I don't know,
Carbala for Shiites, and so on. So
it's still important because it allows you
to guarantee, and especially since sects have
the advantage of diversifying...
The starting point is considerably important,
since sects have never
truly managed to spread
across the globe, guaranteeing a
nearby departure point. And that's still
important because if you
're close to the starting point, at
least you know the body won't have to move too far. There's something
that struck me as very
interesting, though:
in
Jerusalem, I don't remember which radical Jewish sect, they asked for
the Tel Aviv airport to be moved because it
passed over
a traditional Jewish cemetery. This
suggests that the
bodies are indeed launched vertically,
with the risk of the plane colliding with them.
And that's interesting because this vertical launch is one of the most
modern missile launch methods. It's called
vertical launch because it allows the aircraft to launch
in all directions. So that means there's
definitely been
an interesting technological leap.
Well, I don't think the
Israeli authorities ultimately decided to
move it.  The airport,
so the special cases, maybe regarding
the departure points, not sexually obsessed, let's
talk about special cases for
different profiles, or yes, I think
special cases of different departure points, well yes,
because a lot of questions still
arise,
I'm not saying that because it's
the SK affair right now, but you
never know, no, no, no, no, I understand, no, no, that's
sexuality, DSK is
n't a special case, sexuality is
widely discussed in the Old
Testament, I mean Solomon, he had
600 wives, so obviously, I don't know
if DSK reaches those numbers, but
Muhammad officially had, I think,
four wives, but in fact there were
nine living around him, so again, it's
not the case, it's
rather normal, if you will, that's
not the question, uh, well yes, uh,
the stories of the Old
Testament are hilarious, I mean,
the guy who, I don't remember, I
think it's Jacob or Abraham, I don't
remember, anyway, he has his wife at
90 years old, having been unable to have
children  He proposes to his slave,
with whom he has children, and so on.
Finally, his wife decides to
give birth; his wife's son
becomes Israel, and his
slave's son becomes Ishmael. And you
know the inheritance problems
that followed, since ultimately
everyone disputes paternity. Well, between
Jews and Muslims, no, no, the question that
occupied me is,
depending on the nature of the benefits
offered, questions arise.
For example, in the
Muslim Paradise, if you are disabled in
life, do you arrive whole?
If you die at 95,
to honor the 72 virgins, do
you regain the abilities of a 20-year-old,
or not? Well, in the
Christian Paradise, the question doesn't arise
because, ultimately, when we look at
representations of Paradise or the
end times, for example, in
medieval paintings, we get
the impression that people come out of the
tomb covered in blue and white cloth, which
makes them look like endives. And
so  It's really not their
sexual situation that will concern them once
they're in heaven. So,
the question I asked myself was
precisely how to deal with
specific cases like bisexuals,
transsexuals, homosexuals, the
disabled, and so on. And ultimately, we
realize there are many
quite different answers, so
each case needs to be addressed individually because I'm
not going to give away all the information, which
is the result of extensive research. Was there
a particular case
that concerned you? Was it the case of
homosexuals? No? Or not? Uh, why not? Well,
the case of homosexuals... there was
one that I found very amusing, which
was the problem of the
destruction of Sodom and Gomorrah in
the Old Testament. Well, you know that
Sodom and Gomorrah were two
cities that were either
dedicated to female homosexuality or
male homosexuality. Well,
ultimately, God decided to destroy these
two cities and he sent the archangel
Gabriel, who is generally the messenger
of good and evil.  Bad news
then, because he discovered that the only
two righteous people—in fact, the only righteous person in the
two cities—was Lotte, and
so he wants to
save Lotte's family and his own. And,
uh, so when the archangel arrives,
the guys from Sodom, in
particular, immediately see that the guy is quite attractive, well,
that the archangel is quite attractive. They
want to have him, and
the other one offers his daughter to calm them down. That's quite something,
I'd say,
a great act of kindness on his part.
Well, since they're homosexual, in the
end, he gives up. And then, once he
learns the news that
the cities are going to be destroyed, he leaves. He
leaves the
city. His wife, as always in
monotheistic religions, always rebellious, always
incapable, always capable of causing
damage, turns against him despite the
divine prohibition, and finally, by
turning around, she is transformed into a statue of a
saddle. Well, the problem is, since he
's the last man alive on Earth
with his two daughters, the question that never gets answered
until its conclusion is,
ultimately, how to...  He renews
the species since he is the sole
survivor with two children who are his
own, and the Old Testament explains that at
that time, these women, knowing that
the species needed to be renewed, drugged him
to rape him in order to have children by
him. Well, some might
think that this is a legitimization of
pedophilia and incest;
it's a bit scandalous to think of it that way,
but it still leaves room for
doubt. So, you see, there is both
the condemnation of
homosexuality, but at the same time, if the condemnation of
homosexuality is linked
to pedophilia or
incest, we can question
the correct interpretation of the text. I'm going to
ask you a question: have
you discussed this at all with the
managers of these SMEs? Have
you discussed it with the sales representatives?
No, firstly because I had a
religious background, and secondly because
I studied history, so I
mainly tried to understand the evolution of
these religions because of the
characteristic  Of these great
monotheistic religions, some even
claimed that they had taken a
huge step toward intolerance,
since each of these monotheistic religions
explained its primary principle: "My God is
the good one, the only one," which isn't exactly
the right way to discuss things with
others. So the question is,
once the holy text is defined—and
each of these religions has its own—the
important role is that of the
exegetes. That is to say, to explain that
this text contains everything, and therefore, one
must find the answer to every
situation within it. And so these exegetes, whether
religious hierarchy, imam,
Grand Mosque, or
Sanghir, it doesn't matter, all made
extraordinary intellectual efforts
to explain that, in fact, there was an
answer to everything in the texts. So,
I didn't discuss it with them; I became much
more interested in
these different versions which, throughout
their history, had allowed for saying
one thing and its opposite. Where it
became much more interesting is that
The sects were initially... there were
two revolutions. The first,
obviously, was the sects, which, once again,
considerably diversified
the offerings, significantly renewed the
vision of Paradise, the means of accessing it,
and
so on. Because within the sects, there are
also uhological sects, that is to say,
P sects. So, Raël... there,
he guarantees you... he
guarantees you... So what's interesting
in Raël's case is that this guy
had a background as a
race car driver, and in fact, he
never used his superpowers to
win a race. So we must commend the
man's intellectual honesty
because, ultimately, one might have thought
that he alone was capable of
using his superpowers in all cases. Well,
he explained that he had been
abducted by little
green men—I don't know if they were green
or another color—but in any
case, he had been raised by abductees and that
he had been taught the
superpowers with which he formed his
sect, and so he denounced the...
The French legislation
prohibiting genetic manipulation,
because it was said we have the possibility
of creating a race of supermen, the
last one who tried
supermen was Hitler if I remember
correctly, but anyway, he wasn't, he didn't
talk about little green men, so
if you want, there are all these sects
of guys who claim that
flying saucers, little green men, and so on, well,
sects are very
interesting because in general
they have moved to the stage of
the Internet, do you
think Google is a sect, Google or
not, why Facebook? No, no, no, no,
no, I think we mustn't confuse them.
Sects are really a guru, a
guy who has a discourse, however
extraordinary it may be, and above all a
form of social organization that is a
total control over the community with a
discourse. You describe Google, ah,
why Google? Google with its leader
who wants to improve the human race, who... ah,
I don't know, I haven't followed. Well,
maybe we should include him, but it's my
text, it's old, it's from  Back in 2004,
Google didn't have such a
significant role, but it's especially true that
sects have developed the use
of the internet. We see this with
Salafists today; it means
we can easily browse the available content
without much effort. And
even within the major
monotheistic religions, there's an increasing amount of
communication via the internet or
television. For example,
American televangelists are
formidable commercial enterprises where they
promise you paradise, and often
even announce the date of the end of the world—
a sliding date, mind you,
because, as someone once said, every
day brings us closer to the end of the world.
Which is true—a prediction
unlikely to be contradicted. So, these
televangelists
operate like the TV imams and
televangelists from Egypt or the
Gulf, giving
religious sermons with promises,
explanations of behaviors in
daily life, and so on. And then there are
many websites where they
promise you...  For
example, I'll mention a website that
promises you a visit to Paradise, which
is an American sect. There's a
website that sells you Islamist sites,
selling you
Paradise centers, and if you pay by credit card you
get a discount. So there are tons
of things to discover. What the
internet offers allows for a very
well-organized visit. I can ask you
a slightly more personal question: do
you believe in God?
I don't know, we've never met. The
problem is he wasn't very
interested in me, so I don't know.
When you know the phrase from '68
that said "God is dead," signed Nietzsche,
and the guy had written underneath, "
Nietzsche is dead," signed God, there you have it. We're
in that position
today, a revival of religions. This
revival of religions is
unfortunately taking
sectarian forms for many of them, and
these sectarian forms are
incredibly threatening to
democracy. And you're talking about democracy...
uh, in your opinion, what is being
put in place...  Having a
dialogue with these SMEs with the State;
the State is trying to have a dialogue with
its SMEs; do you...  I think this
dialogue will be effective. In
your opinion, is this dialogue
ineffective? Do you have any advice,
perhaps given more? There are
several democratic countries that have taken
different stances, right? For
the Americans, who are by nature a
refuge for all these sects that
were persecuted in Europe, the
principle of religious independence
is total. That is to say, the State
refuses to have any
religious discourse or to condemn anything. And
Scientology is elevated to the
status of a religion and Scientology is
recognized as a religion. That said, being
recognized as a religion means absolutely
nothing in the United States since, once again, there is
no status for
religions. It's considered a
business. Televangelists can
make millions of dollars in revenue.
It's not considered the same as for
us. If you want to talk about abuse of
weakness, in the case of France it's
a little different because in the case
of France the government forbids itself
from having religious discourse. It
simply considers that, in the case of
sects, for example...  Only
practices that infringe upon
individual rights are condemnable;
that means abuse of weakness,
child abduction, things like
that, or psychological manipulation, etc.
Therefore, MIVILUDES, the interministerial mission for monitoring and combating
sectarian abuses, only focuses on
practices condemnable under the
penal code, that's all, but not in the name of
freedom of religion.
So it's very difficult; we can't
discuss with them. Again,
you know how to bring down a
transcendent figure by giving
civics lessons; we haven't had much
success in that area, it's
true. I'd like you to read me the
foreword to your book
concerning tolerance. The
foreword is on page
9. I'll let you
continue. Well, that's a sentence I
found during my travels, a
sentence by Carl Pauper
in his book on the open society
and its enemies: "If we are
absolutely tolerant, even towards the
intolerant, and we do not defend..."  Not a
tolerant society against attacks,
against their attacks, the tolerant
will be annihilated, and with them, the
tolerant society. I find that to be a
common-sense statement, meaning that indeed, that's what it is at a certain point. What
Robesperre said was, "No freedom for
the enemies of freedom." So there comes a point
where democracy,
human rights, and freedom of
speech find their own limits, particularly
when we end up, for example, with
sectarian practices, which are
practices of exploitation of man by
man, or when we end up with calls
for violence or calls for murder.
We are in the 21st century. Do you
think our French society is
more or less tolerant? I think it is
much more so. In any case,
it is much more than all the people
who condemn it, claiming it is
intolerant. When you hear—I listened
the other day on a radio program—
interviews conducted in the suburbs with
young Muslims who
still admired...  The attacks that took place
in January explained that their pleasure
was to go, their desire was to go
to a Muslim country to
freely live their religion. When
I heard the term "freely," a
deep, inner laugh still tore at me
because I... because
defining freedom by saying "I will
finally be able to freely practice my religion"...
they don't know what
Saudi Arabia is, it's a joke.
Can you elaborate a little on
Saudi Arabia? Well, Saudi Arabia is a
kind of immense theological abyss, that is to
say, there is a
practice of Islam which is Immalism,
which is the most radical
and literal practice, if you will, of
reading the Quran, which triumphed in
Saudi Arabia at the beginning of the 20th
century, practically from the 18th
to the beginning of the 20th century, with the
consecration of both the
Saudi dynasty and the
practice developed by Abdul Wahab.  who
developed Wahhabism. Well, when you
say the consecration of the Al
Saud family, yes, that means the
Al Saud family only seized power through
this association of power, which was
religious power and, at the same time, the
power of force. And so
Saudi Arabia is a rather fantastic country
in which no other religion is
allowed, where Sharia law is applied
in its strictest and most brutal sense. There's
currently
an image circulating on the internet of a video of the
beheading of a woman, a
poor girl from Myanmar. So
I see the rights of the defense before
the Saudi court. How could she
exercise them? She was accused of
mistreating or even killing her
daughter-in-law, I don't know. And she's
executed in a public parking lot with
people milling around, and so on. Well,
I think it's fantastic. If we defend
Saudi Arabia against the
Islamic State, I can say we're going to have a
formidable match. So we have a... you have to
imagine what a city in Saudi
Arabia might be like.  Saudi Arabia, a city
where there are no cinemas, no
theaters, no cultural venues other than
the mosque, and only
shopping malls, one might think that the
only desire one could have is to
leave. The problem with
Saudi Arabia is that Bin Laden
wanted to export this model, since it was essentially
his idea, even if he
disagreed with the Saudi family.
But the model he wanted to
export was the one usually found in
a psychiatric hospital where the mentally ill person
tries to save themselves to find
normalcy outside. He
wanted to export this model, so
paradoxically, from a
psychoanalytic perspective, it deserves
analysis. And so you have a society
in which people live by
appearances, meaning they act as if they are
very devout, but as soon as they
are outside, you witness
the unleashing of all the
most appalling practices.
Money allows, if you will,
production and so on, and then obviously, since
in Saudi Arabia
you can find alcohol if you know the
right distribution networks, you can find
drugs and so forth. You have
alcoholism problems, and
families with money send
their children for detoxification, for
drug treatment and so forth, to very high-end
private clinics. In
Switzerland, that's where you can ensure the
most complete anonymity for this kind of
thing. So we're in a society that
is totally hypocritical but has a
lot of money. So when you're a
hypocrite with a lot of money, you have to be
careful. If you want
money, it's better to maintain your
hypocrisy. If you want to be honest, you
denounce your hypocrisy. And for you, for
you, the most hypocritical are
the Saudis or those who deal with
the Saudis. I don't know because I know, it's
a
difficult question, you know. When Bin
Laden, in his program, back when
he wanted to implement his
The system that we discovered with the
9/11 attacks, he
had designated hypocrites as the enemy.
So, let me reassure you, hypocrites aren't
you and me, okay?
Hypocrites, because otherwise there wouldn't be anyone left on
the
planet. No, hypocrites are
bad believers, bad believers,
that is to say, those who don't believe like
him. In this case, that's what it was, right? So,
if it's the hypocrite category in the
Bin Laden sense of the term, it's an
intra-Muslim quarrel. That's what's happening
now; they're massacring each other between Sunnis and Shiites,
between al-Qaeda and ISIS, and
so on. Unfortunately, there's nothing we can
do for them. They'll discover after
a century that tolerance is
a virtue that the Quran doesn't teach
and that the other major
monotheistic religions don't teach. But anyway, there's not much we
can do. As
for the rest, that is to say, can we
negotiate with the devil?  We've been doing it for
centuries, for
centuries, so I don't know if, once again,
when you negotiate with the devil you
need a long spoon, we
agree on that, but again, we're used to it, right? Uh,
last question,
second to last question: when, when, when
you were led to discuss
this book with other people
involved with law enforcement, with
the military, or
maybe that? No, no, it didn't raise any
questions, that's not where the trouble came from. What's
funny is that once
I was sued for
defamation, and you'll never guess by
whom? The Catholic Church! No, I was
sued for defamation by the Association for the
Defense of the Moral Interests of
the Order of the Solar Temple, the
Solar Temple of the Mandarome, sorry, Mandarome, the Mandarome. You
remember, it was
Gilbert Bourdin, the guy who claimed
every night to be fighting against the
lemurs, I don't know why, the
lemurs, well, that's what he said,
to save the planet, and so you
know  He had built these immense
statues in Provence, which
remained there. Then, a
lawsuit was filed
against him, notably for
pedophilic practices and so on. And since he
died too young, we never knew the end of
the story. Anyway, an
association defending the interests of the world's bad apples once sued me for
defamation solely on this point, that is,
on the fact that I mentioned
the possible pedophilic practices of
Gilbert Bourdin, his real name. So,
in fact, the statute of limitations had expired
because, in matters of defamation, it's
very, very short.
Well,
in matters of defamation, there are
two approaches: either you sue in civil court or
you sue in criminal court. If
you sue in civil court, you
defend yourself without a lawyer; if you sue in criminal court, you have to hire a
lawyer. So they
tried to make me pay for a lawyer, that's all. But since
they lost
because of the statute of limitations, it stopped.
But this is to say that,
contrary to what one might think, the
reactions didn't come from those one would
expect to be the most attacked, perhaps
precisely because they are even
divided on their own
definition of paradise and the means of
accessing it. We'll end this
interview with one last question: if
you had to give advice to the
younger
generations, first, buy my book. It will
allow you to protect yourselves against
excesses of all kinds, against all the
certainties instilled in you by
one group or another. That's an
absolutely important point. Then I would
say that the phrase from Claudel—I
think I quote it at the end—that
every time man has wanted to create
paradise on earth, he has mainly led
directly to hell on earth, and
unfortunately, all the examples I
cite, that is to say, all these fundamentalists
who wanted to create somewhere on the planet
a kind of paradise according to
the most obscurantist principles
that could be invented, whether it was the
Taliban in the time of Kabu or...  Whether it was
Calvin in Geneva
or other examples of this nature,
each time it was a terrifying world
of repression, of prohibitions, of bans on
music, on gambling, on all sorts
of things, of
repression against women. So each
time they gathered in the
most terrifying form
imaginable, hell on earth.
Just one final remark, because
something struck me
at the time of the 9/11 attacks:
in the
hotel room of Mohamed Atta, the
leader of the group, we found a description of
what he thought, of what he believed
awaited him after his death. And so he
said that indeed, he would have,
in Paradise, what had been
promised to him. He had tested it a little
before. Oh no, it's not, it's more
complicated than that. That is to say, he
knew that, as he had been promised, he was
expecting wine that wouldn't make him drunk,
and then 72 virgins. Well, the problem is
that, convinced by the  Saudis, in
this terrible practice of Islam, were, in
my opinion, facing a
profound schizophrenia. Because if you
imagine that for a Saudi, wine and women are still
the
United States, which is described
as hell on earth, and that
hell is described as the
sun, the rock, and the desert—that is,
Saudi Arabia—this
kind of image slippage means
that on Earth we have what is described as hell, and
on
Earth we have what is described as paradise—
Saudi Arabia—to go there and
discover that paradise is what
the United States is, and then hell is what
Saudi Arabia describes. At a point where
the images, if you will,
are like playback, a moment where
the image and sound don't overlap. I do
n't know how he solved the problem. Do
you want to add something? No, there's
a story I found very
good too; it's the story of a
Palestinian woman.  There was an
organized attack with two women taking turns,
each wearing an
explosive belt. The idea
was to do what's often done in
attacks: the first woman would
detonate her belt when the emergency services
arrived to deliver the medication. The second woman was
supposed to detonate her belt.
However, the blast from the
first woman's explosion knocked the second woman unconscious. She
woke up in a
completely white room with people taking care
of her and treating her. She thought, "
I'm in
Paradise." She was still equipped, no,
because at that point she no longer had
her device; it had been dismantled.
She was in a completely
white room with people around
her, a doctor treating her, and
so on. So she thought, "I'm in
Paradise." The people said, "No, you
're not in Paradise, you're not dead." She said, "
But yes, Paradise is like this,
I can see it. There are people
taking care of me."  the guy the
doctor who was there he tried to
convince her she didn't want to convince him
finally he used the
supreme argument he said it's not paradise
since I'm Jewish I'm a
Jewish doctor and all at once for her it
collapsed if you everything that was the
description of her paradise so there you have it you have to
remain modest in the face of the promises
Pierre knows that thank you Thanks to
[Applause]
YOU MAJ [ __ ]
you
Allion
igion religion easily has the greatest
[ __ ] story ever told think about it
religion has actually convinced people
that there's an invisible
man living in the sky who watches
everything you do every minute of every
day and the invisible man has a special
list of 10 things he does not want you
to do and if you do any of these 10
things he has a special place full of
fire and smoke and burning and torture
and anguish where he will send you to
live and suffer and burn and choke and
scream and cry forever and ever till the
end of
time but he loves
you you
he always loves you and he needs
money he needs money he's  all
powerful all perfect all knowing and all
wise somehow just  can't handle
money religion takes in billions of
dollars they pay no taxes and they
always need a little more now you talk
about a good [ __ ] story holy
[ __ ]